how do you create a vaccine to fight a
new disease
and why does it take so long
well first you have to identify the
virus of bacterium that causes the
disease
in some cases the pathogen itself can
then be
weakened or deactivated and used to make
a vaccine
but this isn't always possible in these
cases the next step is to identify the
pathogens antigens
unique protein or glycoprotein markers
which can form the basis of a new
vaccine
for some pathogens these antigens always
stay the same
other pathogens like the virus that
causes flu can
change or mutate their antigens and so
these must be reanalyzed
every year once you have identified the
pathogen or antigens
you need to decide how you are going to
use them to build a vaccine
this is called the vaccine platform
there are a lot of options here like
subunit vaccines
that only use part of the pathogen there
are also newer or more experimental
technologies
like viral vector or nucleic acid-based
vaccines
but we'll get to these a bit later you
also need to decide
how the vaccine will be administered by
injection into the skin or muscle
orally like the polio vaccine or through
the nose
like some flu vaccines each of these
options could affect the response the
vaccine induces
for now let's say you've decided on the
platform
and designed the vaccine next it needs
to be tested
first in cell cultures and then in
animal models this might include
challenge studies where animals that
have been given the vaccine
are deliberately exposed to the target
disease to see if the vaccine protects
them
further down the line and if the disease
isn't too serious or effective
treatments are available
humans might take part in challenge
studies too
once the vaccine candidate is proven
safe in animals
you need to prove you can manufacture it
to a high enough standard for people
and at scale this is called gmp
certification if the vaccine passes all
of these stages
it's time to begin human trials
normally these come in three phases and
they all have to be passed
first the vaccine is given to a small
group of healthy people
to test for adverse reactions this is
called the safety trial
second you give the vaccine to hundreds
of people
to work out what dose is needed to
trigger a big enough immune response
finally you can trial the vaccine in
thousands of people
to see how effective it is this step
is often the slowest and participants
are sometimes recruited around
the world researchers have to wait for
participants to come into contact with
the pathogen
naturally by tracking how many become
infected
they can work out how effective the
vaccine is at protecting the group
it can take decades to gather enough
data to be sure
but if you do the vaccine can finally be
licensed
there are still problems to overcome
however mass producing a vaccine to a
high standard
can be a difficult job and once you've
cracked production
you still have to deliver the vaccine to
where it's needed
and then there's phase four monitoring
keeping track of rare adverse reactions
that the vaccine might cause
even though it's past the previous
trials
this trial process is very safe but that
comes
at a cost it is also very slow
in an emergency there are ways to speed
things up
like reducing the time spent waiting for
paperwork to be completed
or running different trial phases at the
same time
but steps are never missed out by
working more efficiently
a protective vaccine could be produced
in as little as 12 to 18 months
and advances in biotechnology could
speed up production pipelines as well
and there are more ways we could speed
up production
let's come back to some of those newer
vaccine platforms
nucleic acid vaccines don't use
pathogens or antigens directly
instead they deliver the genetic
templates
for the antigens these dna or
rna templates can be delivered directly
or
in lipid nanoparticles that help them to
enter cells
and improve their stability after
injection
these nanoscale fat droplets encapsulate
the rna or dna
protecting it as it enters the body
some lipid nanoparticles can also act as
adjuvants
molecular triggers to kick-start the
immune response
once inside the body these dna or rna
templates
instruct our cells to start making
antigens which activate the immune
response needed
to build immunity rna and dna
are much easier and faster to produce in
the lab than androgens are
they're also potentially safer than
vaccines that contain
whole pathogens that means they could
hopefully be used by people with
weakened immune systems but nucleic acid
vaccines
are still experimental another approach
is called a viral vector viral vector
vaccines work by inserting an
incomplete segment of genetic material
from a pathogen
inside a harmless virus that doesn't
cause disease
this then acts as a vehicle for the
genetic material
delivering it to the right place in the
body where it can be translated into
proteins
triggering the immune system the viral
vector may even be self-replicating
increasing the amount of vaccine in the
body viral vector vaccines are also
quick to produce
safe vectors have already been
established and it is relatively easy to
insert
different target genetic material into
these established carriers
and as the genetic material inserted is
incomplete
they can't replicate and cause disease
so they're also
very safe but there is only so much the
process can be spread along
effective vaccines can save millions of
lives
but before they are used they have to be
proven to be safe
and effective in the future researchers
hope to develop vaccines against
non-infectious diseases like cancers
based on chemical markers
called tumor neoantigens vaccine
technology
is developing every day and it has a
bright future
albeit a slow and methodical one
[Music]
you